MARIA: WELCOME BACK, WE ARE BACK
WITH STEPHEN MILLER, THE FOUNDER
OF AMERICA FIRST LEGAL.
STEPHEN, YOU EXPLAINED TITLE 42
REALLY WELL AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT BECAUSE THIS IS THE CRUX OF
THE REALLY DETERRENT FOR PEOPLE
TO COME AND THERE ISN'T ANY
DETERRENT RIGHT NOW.
JOHN SOLOMON IS REPORTING THAT
THERE'S A BIPARTISAN CALL FOR
BIDE ON THE APPOINT A NEW BORDER
TSAR.
APPARENTLY KAMALA HARRIS BEING
CRITICIZED AS SHE CONTINUES TO
SEARCH FOR THE ROOT CAUSES OF
THIS ILLEGAL MIGRATION.
REPRESENTATIVE HENRY CUELLAR AND
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM ARE
ASKING PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
APPOINT FORMER HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY JAY JOHNSON TO A
SPECIAL EXECUTIVE POSITION TO
MANAGE THE BORDER CRISIS
ACCORDING TO JOHN SOLOMON, YOUR
THOUGHTS ON WHAT KAMALA HARRIS
IS DOING IN THE FACE OF ALL OF
THIS?
STEPHEN: YES, FOR ONE THING I
THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S POLITICAL
AMBITIONS ARE EFFECTIVELY
DESTROYED AS A RESULT OF HER
ADMINISTRATION OF THE BORDER.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT SHE'S NOT THE
ONE MAKING THE POLICY DECISIONS.
THE POLICY DECISIONS ARE BEING
MADE BY THE FACELESS RADICALS
THROUGHOUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WHO ARE RUNNING
THE SHOW.
THEIR WHITE HOUSE STAFF, DHS
STAFF, MOST OF WHOM WILL NEVER
BE KNOWN TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC,
WHO ARE MAKING THESE TRULY,
TRULY DEADLY DECISIONS THAT ARE
RESULTING IN DRUGS, DISEASE
CRIME AS WELL AS JUST
LARGE-SCALE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
THAT DRAINS OUR FINANCES AND
DESTROYS AMERICAN LIFE AND
WEALTH.
I TOTALLY AGREE THE VICE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE REPLACED BUT
ULTIMATELY SHE'S ONLY BEING USED
AS THE FAL